les migrants vénézuéliens sont
désinfectés puis on vérifie leur santé
avant de leur laisser passer la
frontière du pays en crise qu'ils ont
fui le venezuela la générosité de la
colombie et mise à l'épreuve de lakovic
le pays qui a accueilli la plus grande
partie des 5 millions d'exilés du
venezuela
maintenant les refoule revenez bientôt
la colombie vous attend est devenue un
slogan un peu mensonger
la colombie a fermé ses frontières sauf
celle ci est dans une seule direction
on nous a jetés comme des chiens de nos
logements des fois sans pouvoir
récupérer nos affaires
sans argent dans la rue officiellement
on ne met pas les vénézuéliens à la
porte mais ils ne peuvent plus payer
leur loyer faute de travail généralement
dans les rues à vendre des objets ou des
aliments parce qu'il n'y a plus personne
ils ont peur de retourner au venezuela
parce que le venezuela est minée par le
corona virus on craint la pénurie de
puteaux de médicaments de médecins car
beaucoup sont en exil en fait venezuela
on doute de tout des chiffres du
gouvernement qui déclare très peu de cas
de la capacité des habitants à respecter
les consignes d'isolement pour les plus
pauvres c'est très difficile ils doivent
gagner leur vie ils dépendent de ce hack
ils vont vendre dans les rues les
masques artisanaux cache une grande
détresse
le manque d'accès à l'eau potable est ce
qu'il y a plus dangereux
on ne peut pas le vêlage cette eau est
pour le strict minimum ajoute-t-il
profiter de l'épidémie pour tenter de se
débarrasser une fois plus de nicolás
maduro
d'abord le secrétaire à la justice
billboard a mis sur la liste des
recherchés pour trafic de drogue et aux
pays bas
maduro les autres ont trahi le peuple
est corrompu les institutions je te le
dis tu es un misérable donald trump tu
agis comme un cow-boy raciste et
suprémacistes qui pratiquent les
relations internationales comme un
extorqueurs ces derniers jours
l'administration américaine s'est
adoucie en proposant un gouvernement
provisoire avant la tenue d'élections
présidentielles opposant wang wei d'eau
qui comme nicholas maduro ne pourrait
pas en être membres à accepter la
proposition silence du côté du
gouvernement maduro qui vient d'accuser
juan garrido de tentative de coup d'état
bref dans ce déjà vu la seule inconnue à
présent c'est l'effet du facteur
pandémie sur le blocage politique
jean michel leprince radio canada